hello I'm Nik gowing and welcome to
Cadogan Hall in London for an
intelligence squared debate stop poking
the bear the West needs to engage with
Putin not castigate him well relations
between the west and Russia are at their
lowest ebb since the Soviet Union
collapsed 23 years ago and of course the
end of the Cold War as well Russia's
Swift annexation of Crimea from Ukraine
led to the US and European Union
imposing sanctions on many of those
closest to blad Emir Putin and the
Russian president is determined to
create a new assertive Russia
novorossiya so our harsh words and
sanctions designed to be punitive the
way to get Putin's Russia to reconsider
and back off or should there be smarter
understanding of Putin's determination
to restore Russian status and influence
in the world we have an excellent panel
to debate these issues here in London
arguing for the motion is so Tony
Brenton a former British ambassador to
Russia and Sega kerrigan off Russian
foreign and economic affairs specialist
and adviser to the Russian government
arguing against the motion
Julia Yaffe of the New Republic magazine
in Washington
born in Russia her experience is in
Russian politics and society your
expertise there and Edward Lucas author
of the new Cold War senior editor at The
Economist ladies and gentlemen your
panelists speakers tonight
shortly you're here from the four
speakers to for the motion to against I
will then throw the debate open to you
on the floor and the audience has been
polled before the debate I'll give you
those results after you've heard from
our four speakers the audience will then
vote again at the end and they will
discover we will all discover how the
debate has swung views or not now let's
get the opening statements from each of
the four speakers speaking first for the
motion see Tony Brenton British
ambassador to Russia between 2004 and
2008 during his time there he monitored
the Kremlin's reaction to the orange
revolution in Ukraine and the Russian
military operation and occupation of
parts of Georgia ladies gentlemen
certainly Brenton
thank you very much Nick
one of the right things about Russia is
that in a political crisis like the one
we're experiencing what it does produce
in quantity is mordant political jokes
so let me start off with one of those
which is President Putin sitting in the
Kremlin and the divisor that comes up to
him and says mr. president those
Americans are so stupid even with all
the present publicity 64% of them cannot
find Ukraine on the map to which mr.
Putin replies and very shortly none of
them will be able to that's to help the
opposition get going in this debate mr.
Putin is indeed talking about
novorossiya and looking after
russian-speaking communities overseas
creating all sorts of fears amongst
those who follow Russia here and Edward
I saw in an interview at the beginning
of the week was asking what next they
can turn off the gas Moldova Latvia the
bear is on the prowl again now I'm sorry
but I'm afraid that position but that
position is simply nonsense and the
motion that we're inquired we're looking
at today inviting us to consider not
castigating Putin but engaging with him
the the slightly nicer diplomatic term
for castigating is containing wonderful
Cold War term so I'm going to say there
are very good reasons why we should not
try to contain Putin it is unnecessary
it is unachievable and if tried it would
be counterproductive let me take those
three points in turn first of all it's
unnecessary you look at the issue of
Crimea annexed illegally contrary to a
lot of commitments that Russia had given
it is unique in its history and in the
justification which the Russians felt
they had for doing what they did as they
saw it the the Maidan revolution all of
that was a Western concocted Western
driven attempt to take over after all
the country
Ukraine which in many ways is closest to
them it was unique case it is not a case
which threatens to happen again
in Moldova or Latvia or any of those
other splendid places while the rather
lay
the British press has talked about the
bear being on the prowl again if you
actually look at Russia it's no longer a
bear
Russia has about half of the population
of the United States about 1/8 of the
GDP of the United States about 1/10 of
the motor of the defense spending of the
United States this isn't a bear it's a
small accredited badger something
smaller now it's a creature which of
course has sharp claws and that's Russia
it's not out there taking over the world
it's reacting to what it sees as a
Western attack on it so containment is
unnecessary containment is unachievable
at the same time as President Obama in
particular but also mr. Haig here we're
talking about isolating Russia mr. Putin
was in was in Shanghai signing a really
historic 400 billion dollar gas
agreement with China the Chinese but not
only the Chinese the Indians the
Brazilians
the major developing powers who are
countries which you would have expected
to be deeply critical of the Russian
action because there are countries do
not like big countries taking pieces of
other countries have all remained
carefully mute on what the Russians have
been up to it is a striking fact that
even after all the rhetoric we've seen
over the last two months
the French are still building two
warships for Russia so containment
simply is unachievable and you know how
can you contain a country which by some
measures is very shortly going to be the
largest economy in Europe and which
provides Europe with 25% of its gas an
achievable unnecessary and if tried
counterproductive the impact of the
current approach on the standing of the
Putin's government of the Putin
governments in in Russia and British
cycling has gone up from 60% to 80%
popularity you are looking at a Western
approach which is pushing the what the
wagons around the Russian people where
they're saying to themselves our
president is standing up against the
evil overweening West
we're with him is that what the result
we want to achieve that's the result
we're currently creating by this attempt
to isolate and contain so unnecessary
unachievable counterproductive the
alternate
approach has to be engagement and that
was working as we engaged with Russia
the Russians got richer the Russians
became more involved more linked with
the West they were moving in our
direction as the big demonstrations in
2011-2012 demonstrated we need to get
back to that so please vote for the
resolution thank you
so toady Brenton thank you very much
indeed I have to tell you we're not
changing the motion to stop poking the
Badger it is still stop poking the bear
now let's hear the first voice against
the motion
Giulio a welcome Russian born senior
editor of the American Journal the New
Republic she's reported extensively from
Russia having been born there and has
recently been reporting on the ground
from eastern Ukraine Julia the floor is
yours
you know this notion that we shouldn't
poke the bear and we should just engage
with it it's a really nice and
comforting one it's the notion that if
you don't poke the bear or the badger
whatever animal we decide on tonight it
just won't roar the picture that my
opponents are going to paint for you
tonight is that what did we do to
provoke this bear badger you know it's
it's a backwards logic especially
because the bear itself is hiding behind
this logic it's you know it's licking
the honey off its paws and saying you
know what you're right you guys made me
do this let's quickly start with NATO
expansion which has been the big
boogeyman that NATO expansion has
antagonized Russia and this is why it's
taking parts of Ukraine ladies and
gentlemen when was the last time that
NATO expanded when was the last time it
took in a new member country 2009 was
five years ago which countries did it
accept into the Alliance Croatia and
Albania do they share a border with
Russia no are they in Russia's backyard
not really in its sphere of influence
not really
EU expansion you know it's it's notable
that we've not been talking about
Ukraine at all here as an actual country
with 46 million people who may or may
not want certain things and as we've
seen over the last month's they want
different things inside the country but
just saying that you know the West
promised Russia that it wouldn't take
Poland or in the Baltic States in I mean
who is who is Russia and who is the web
just to decide the fates of these
countries and this anti-western rhetoric
and aggression inside Russia did not
start in February when little green men
appeared in Crimea it didn't even start
in November with that when then
ukrainian President Viktor Yanukovych
did not backed away from signing an
agreement with EU it started much much
earlier
it started in December 2011 that fall
Vladimir Putin announced that he was
coming back for a third presidential
term and the four years under Dmitry
Medvedev four years of thaw and
modernisation were all a joke and they
were over then in December
his people basically stole a
parliamentary election and Russians with
smartphones captured this on on on their
phones shared it online with other
Russians and very soon in fact the next
day the resentment at being treated like
idiots by their government
Russians spilled out into the street and
all of a sudden Vladimir Putin was faced
with a hundred thousand one hundred
fifty thousand Russians protesting not
just corruption not just a stolen
election but against him personally so
searching for a culprit for these
protests he and his advisers settled on
the US State Department soon Russian
state television was running so-called
documentaries saying that the State
Department was actually funding all the
protesters who had come out to protest
against Putin and they were paying them
with money and sometimes with cookies
with cookies at the same time Vladimir
Putin had a presidential election to win
that March and this became a very handy
campaign ploy so you can either go with
the with this fifth column
these pro-western protesters who are
paid for by the State Department or you
can go with me
Vladimir Putin who is standing between
you and the void between you and a
craven wet West that wants to invade you
and humiliate you and carve you up and
destroy you and what we've seen in the
last two years is this anti Western
anti-american rhetoric climbed to a
fever pitch
so yes the West did play an important
role in Russia's turn against the West
but it's not the actual West or anything
the West actually
did it was this mythical West that
exists in the minds of Russia's
television producers and Kremlin
advisors because what was happening in
2011-2012
between Russia and the West when all of
this started happening things with
Britain were getting a lot better with
the youth with the u.s. they were
absolutely peachy
we had a New START treaty that
drastically reduced nuclear armaments we
had a transit route open up through
Russian territory for the u.s. to supply
its troops in Afghanistan and yet this
it was during this period that the that
Russia turned against the West so things
just don't line up just because we
engage with Russia doesn't mean they
won't turn against the West so the last
point is yes we can engage with Russia
and by all means we should but let's not
let's not overestimate ourselves and
let's not underestimate the Russians
thank you
the first voice against the motion
Giulia Yaffe thank you very much indeed
now our second and final speaker for the
motion Sega Kerrigan off from Moscow a
Russian economic and foreign affairs
specialist on read chairman of the
Presidium of the Council on foreign and
defense policy in Moscow Sega Kerrigan
it is indeed a great pleasure to speak
for the bear he is the smartest the most
vicious the bravest and of course he is
clever
so I like the bear and my educated
advice do not poke the bear and of
course do not let us not fool ourselves
when we are talking about Lemire Putin
we are talking about Russia now to the
most serious points the origins of the
current crisis lies in the fact that the
West has been around the super suing the
Cold War for almost 25 years since the
day it was proclaimed finished it was a
rental pursuing it by endless expansion
of NATO against Russian arguments please
and protists especially irritating for
Russia were of course the philistine
Statesman's the arguments that these
expansion as well as the expansion of
European Union are not against the arson
interests that brought about I mean of
course a feeling of humiliation but also
distrust we tried to persuade we offer
to sign several times and you security
treaty we offered an idea of signing of
building up an alliance of Europe for
Dublin or breasts to give a stock with
an open space for people goods with the
common rules or everything has been
rejected indeed an open wound remained
at the center of Europe the last time it
was the Ukrainian infection to prevent
things from getting worse
russia was awash are castrated in a very
sophisticated way reunion of Crimea with
the with the mother country of course
people outside didn't like that let me
remind you that the previous red line
was drawn when Georgia another candidate
for a NATO membership at attacked and
killed Russian peacekeeper UN
peacekeepers in South I see a South
Ossetia with a full support of the West
at naita originally we defeated that
aggression and hoped that will stop the
roundest expansion of the Western sphere
of influence where do we go from now it
is very clear we will go from now even
down Europe will stay divided with the
crisis which will be sucking our
energies for decades while others will
grow at our expense is their way out mmm
probably yes one easy one leaders of the
West write a collective letter
congratulating Vladimir Putin I mean he
did exactly what West has been doing
over all these years he repeated the
lessons of Yugoslavia which was invaded
and crushed and Kosovo was torn away we
could of course go on like that
I'm not sure whether the Western leaders
have the guts to cite such a letter
though it would have been a smart
gesture we should resume
talking and aim at what I would call a
grand alliance and at a final end of the
Cold War let us think about finishing
that ugly episode in our history forever
by for example signing a treaty for the
Alliance of Europe creating and Commons
economic human and energy space of all
Europe from Dublin to the US talk which
will strengthen us all be magnanimous
the bear is a powerful animal thank you
Sergei Kharitonov thank you very much
indeed the second voice for the motion
now the second voice against the motion
edward lucas for over 20 years foreign
correspondent based in Berlin Prague
Vienna Moscow and the Baltic state I
should say that his book the new cold
war rang alarm bells about the likely
threats Vladimir Putin posed both for
Russia and the West
Edward Lucas speaking against the motion
first of all I just want to say I
absolutely reject this premise that if
you bash Putin you bash Russia because
Putin is the number one Russia Basha
it's his regime which is Miss rule
Russia for the last 15 years it's his
regime which has stolen tens of billions
of dollars from the Russian people and
laundered it here it's an absolute
fiction to say as they used to say in
Soviet areas the general said she loves
the nation and the nation loves the
general secretary this is a regime which
practices Olympic star corruption I mean
Olympic star corruption which silences
and bullies and jails and sometimes
murders anyone who gets in way of the
root of the of the looting machine and
LaserJet what we tried engagement we
tried engagements in the 1990s and we
poured billions of dollars into the
Yeltsin regime to try and profit profit
out which is a terrible terrible mistake
and even after that tens more billions
of dollars coming the other way being
laundered in the great financial centers
of the West there are business class
seats ladies and gentlemen on the
Kremlin gravy train and they're filled
by our bankers who do these deals by our
lawyers who check them to make sure they
look legal by our accountants who cook
the books by the consultants who think
of ever more ingenious schemes by the PR
people who try and make it look good
talk about taking 30 silver roubles that
was engagement I wish you'd had less of
it and NATO engage we set up the
nato-russia Council where we allowed a
nest of spy
in the heart of NATO or with NATO badges
they could walk in and out of meetings
just to try and soothe the Russians from
their sense of supposed insecurities and
we paid a huge price that we paid a
price in our self-respect we paid a
price for our standing in Russia and we
paid a price in the terms of our allies
security because they warned us the
Estonians the Latvians Lithuanians the
poles the Czechs the Slovaks they warned
us about this they are the people who
understand Russia really well they lived
inside the Soviet empire and under
Soviet occupation and they warned us
watch out for energy don't let Europe
become dependent on Russian energy they
warned us that geopolitics is back they
warned us that the Kremlin
doesn't like countries that have real
elections like when we just had in
Ukraine where you didn't know at the
beginning who was going to win now I
greet Ukraine's in a terrible mess I
would suggest that Russia's help made it
that way I agree the Ukrainian elite has
been abominable but the point is the
Ukrainian people try to change it they
try to do something that Russia
absolutely hates we just have a
sovereign choice about their country's
future and they looked at the European
Union and they said we want that we want
the liberty the decency the dignity that
a gala see the choice we want the things
that you've got that's why they died in
blood spattered European flags and
Russia didn't want to have that because
they Russian knows that a successful
democratic Ukraine is an existential
threat for the crony capitalist regime
in the Kremlin our East European
neighbors warned us that the Kremlin
doesn't believe in win-win the Kremlin
likes win lose with them winning and
asked losing and so what did we say to
the Estonians and Latvians Lithuanians
and Czechs and poles people like that
South Havel these great moral Giants
who'd been in prison under communism and
who warned us about this
I'll tell you what we did we'd
patronized them we ignored them we
belittle them we said that they were
suffering from post-traumatic stress
disorder that they didn't have the right
sentences perspective they didn't get
the big picture
Russia's willing to do three things it's
willing to use force it's willing to
accept economic pain and it's going to
lie relent
and shamelessly what should we do in
return let's let NATO beam NATO and do
its job and defend our East European
allies let the EU be the EU and unleash
its competition authority on the Gazprom
t treat Gazprom like Microsoft enforce
our own laws here look at these
companies with mysterious ownership
mysterious business business practices
which have become so immensely rich here
and let's not forget that in the end
this isn't just about the freedom of the
Russians who are suffering under this
autocratic kleptocratic regime
it's about ours too as the Russian said
said memorably on red square in 1968
it's for your freedom and ours our
vassal in national spa border
Edouard Lucas thank you very much indeed
well before I open the floor to all of
you and let's start moving the
microphones around please let me just
tell you what you were thinking when you
came into this debate the result well
the views that you had at that point
were 31 percent of you one third of you
still don't know 23% were against the
motion would have voted it down and 46%
were needing to engage with Russia as
opposed to the tougher line we're
hearing from those against the motion so
that is what still has to be argued over
from both sides let's hear the views
from the gentleman standing up in the
middle at the moment I'm surprised that
we continue to speak of the annexation
of Crimea it seems that the vote that
took place there the referendum is
totally disregarded despite the fact
that the West says oh we're all for
democracy and we respect the vote and
the wish of the people the media
coverage that is we have in this country
as well as in the west of what's
happened in Russia and what's happened
in Ukraine is extraordinarily biased
right who as the microphone over here
which way you voting I'm also voting for
the motion Russia has always had a
balance between is it a Western looking
power or Eastern looking power he said
our interest that it looks west not East
thank you who's got the microphone there
please yeah my question to the
proponents are how far do they think
that the media is biased because and the
sanctions are biased because of jealousy
by the US and the EU over Russians plan
for Eurasian Union and ultimately a
single currency store that question and
one more please thank you I was born in
Ukraine yes could you tell us which way
you'll vote against against Putin from
18 of March I became very against
and when we all talk so calmly whether
to poke or not as a bear badger it's
unbelievable the referendum in Crimea is
absolutely out of any order and good
neighbors will never lose someone house
if country is weak I would agree with
mr. Corrigan in only one point Ukraine
was an East probably in bad state but it
does not mean like you have to kick
Ukraine as much as you want and bring
tanks to Crimea and tomorrow go to
Donetsk to create all this Ukrainian
never invaded for 1000 year thank you so
you can talk like this thank you we've
got a message would you bet he
absolutely destroyed every trust to
Russia from my country from everyone
else could you remove the microphone
thank you
Sega Kerrigan off as direct challenge
there from a Ukrainian about the
reputation of Russia and particularly
what's happening in the Kremlin under
President Putin first of all I mean one
thousand years was our common history
most of this period I mean it was Russia
the second but of course I hope that a
crane survives I mean I really
then of course about this negative
reporting I must say that this negative
reporting na they're a caricature you
have exactly have heard contributed very
much to the fate of Ukraine the ad like
information in the Western press was
total by the time of the Olympics and
Russian elite decided that I mean that a
pose of containment is being returned
so with rather strike first so so it is
you at at second Eurasian Union was of
course one of the quite vegetarian
notion how do you create an economic
Union when you are squandering the
wealth of Russia of course we're
squandering a lot of our resources and
I'm very sad about that and I'm said
about about our the fact that our
plutocrats are exporting money and
that's why I agree with IDI that what
the West should do its best to stop that
and by the way what is done by the some
of the sanctions I hope they work is
exactly what Putin is calling he wants
to nationalize elites and to cut short
their habit of sending money abroad even
though is you're close to him even
though by the way those who are closely
we have no money or else have taken the
money back and then nobody has found any
money
I'm sorry nobody has found any money of
people who are close to him or his money
which were rumors anywhere right and
that is a fact of life I'm sorry I'm
having a very unusual position I'm
defending I mean I'm in Putin's friends
I am NOT doing that in Russia
I'm validate the argument let me hear
from the other side here economy your
economy is doing so great that it's now
officially in a recession having
contracted for two quarters
consecutively as for the Eurasian Union
it was signed with Putin and two or
three other people at the table
nope no other takers so our is the US
jealous no ed would um I think I just
want to come there was an interesting
point made about um would Russia turn
east and my friend on drapion cough ski
put this very well when he said any
alliance between Russia and China would
be an alliance between a rabbit and a
bur constrictor with Russia playing the
role of the rabbit just to add to the
badger that we had earlier on so I do
and I think he was astonishing that
Putin arrived in Beijing to do this gas
deal and basically gave the Chinese
everything they wanted it was the worst
deal imaginable from a Russian point is
you absolutely you sorry but I don't
know how you know that I I can tip well
so is Tony hang on a mo no no Wendling
well I'm just keep reading The Economist
and you'll find out all these things of
your product um
all right I I just I just also want to
come back on a couple of points about
Ukraine um this point about the
referendum this is this is delusional
and also what about the Crimean Tatars
taking from their beds in the middle of
the night in 1944
half of them died hundreds of thousands
of people taken their beds half of them
died within the first year they come
back to Crimea their only hope of
justice is being within a democratic no
law governs you crash at only brenton
you took issue with Edward Lucas yes I
think of course I will read The
Economist especially since their
coverage my letters these days
where do you get your data from by
reading all the rest of the press who
have been much less certain than Edward
seems to feel able to be on this deal
certainly there was argument about the
price and about the terms but the
outcome in the majority of the press is
that the Russians may have to connect
could see a bit which I'm sure is right
but have not settled for a disastrous
deal at all and the main point about
this deal apart from the immediate price
is that it creates a major new gas
superhighway right across Siberia which
is only good not only good for the next
ten years but is a new bond between
Russia and China now okay rabbit and
Burr constrictor whatever you like the
fact is that there is a natural
complementarity between those two
economies you have a vast natural
resource producing Russia on one side
and a vast natural resource hungry
China on the other side we and there are
other links neither of them much like
the West
neither of them much like human rights
neither of them much like our
interventions on behalf of democracy
they have set up an organization the
Shanghai Cooperation Organization which
is deliberately designed to exclude the
US and to create a sort of unified
approach to developments in Central Asia
so I am going on to lock but the main
point is we may sublimely tell ourselves
they ain't going to happen
it's happening I want to get more views
particularly on the motion which were
you voting yes or no in favor yes in
favor of the motion for the West deals
there's all kinds of unpleasant regimes
Russia is closer in spirit to the west
and by alienating it all we're doing is
pushing it further into very
dangerous nationalism and we have to
think very carefully about what the
alternative is to puts in before before
we start launching into this kind of
rhetoric thank you
who's got the microphone up there please
which way you voting I'm leaning towards
against I just want to say we've looked
a lot in the past but one of the future
today is Russia tomorrow is China the
tiger how do how we deal with Russia
today and how we poke Russia today
influence of how China responds to the
west tomorrow thank you one more voice
from up at the back please in which way
you are wanting to vote I'm against
promotion and I must say I smile when I
hear people talking about the biased
media in the West Village Russia if you
want to see some really biased media
look at Russian state TV where everyone
who opposes putin is denigrated as a
Nazi and Nazi sympathizer a sexual
sexual degenerate or a fifth columnist
one of the things that is really turning
the bear into a frenzied and dangerous
monster is its own media thank you you
can't come in here thank you for the
emotion and my just very quick question
is to those who are against you know you
said that it's Russia was engaged the
maximum level how did it how do you
determine it was at the maximum level
did you not see more capacity to engage
Russia what about that challenge to your
position against the motion and Edward
you wanted to jump in immediately but
the lady there who said why vilify
Russia because Russia is a threat to
European security Europe has built up
but are there other countries as well
but they're long they're further away I
mean we have lots of problems lots of
countries but I'm worried about European
security right now because we have an
alliance I'm called NATO where we are
committed to defend NATO members and I
Tony said with enormous confidence that
um this was get this was going to stop
in Ukraine and I can't help remembering
that it was only a few months ago he
said the idea that Russia would seize
Crimea was dark fantasy and if you look
at what the book that Russia is doing it
is waging economic warfare and waging
information warfare against the Baltic
States and we've looked very weak in
response we're not prepared
to accept economic pain we are not
prepared to reinforce our allies Julia
um and and and I think the sets in a
very worrying precedent to the gentleman
in the gallery
I'm not against engaging with Russia
what I'm saying is we have to keep in
mind that Russia is its own animal and
it does things not only because we're
doing things to them Russia does things
because of its own internal logic
because of its own internal processes
this turn against the West happened at a
moment of great US Russia cooperation
joint military exercises allowing a US
military transport through Russian
territory Russians being the only ones
to launch American astronauts into space
I can go on the point is that we were
cooperating and Russia for its own
reasons turned away we can continue to
engage in them but we also have to keep
in mind that it's not just we're not the
ones setting the tune here we have to
keep in mind what's happening in Russia
as well you have to think not only about
Russia but about yourself here in the
West Europe is in a very very difficult
position the European project is in
crisis clearly years from now Europe
most probably will be weaker so and one
of the reasons why we have this crisis
is that some people in Europe wanted to
create it at this crisis to divert
attention from the real problems we did
by the way you're a lot of allowing me a
lot of a lot of people in Russia a few
people in Russia wanted also to create
this crisis and an external threat from
quote and called the West also to
distract attention from the problems
within the country so we could with this
kind of object we are doomed to be
secondary or in your case true theory
what about the voices were hearing of
those who want to vote against the
motion who are essentially saying we
don't believe Russia well I am sorry off
trying President Putin said he would we
go into idea what happens neck
after 20 years of our relations with our
Western friends and I was not speaking
about personal racial we do not trust
the West it is the result of Western
polls as MSA security brain again let us
think rationally
Edwin makes a very interesting point
he's charged that Russia is a security
threat to us and Sergei responds to it
by saying we the Russians view you as a
security threatening to us to be
included well that's okay the ratio Dino
do go I don't want to exaggerate this
but if indeed Russia is a security
threat to us which I don't think it's
true but if we view it as a security
threat to us and they undoubtedly
Russians I know say expanding NATO
moving into places which are sacred to
us like Ukraine Georgia so on and so
forth you are undoubtedly trying to
encircle us we're in a situation with
clear parallels to August 1914 which
brings me back to my original argument
the way you diffuse this stuff is not by
prodding whatever animal it is it's by
getting the temperature down engaging at
a peaceful level so just be clear Tony
Brenton you thought there was no chance
of an intervention or annexation of
Crimea and therefore we're coming down
back to that question I just put two
Sergey Kerrigan off the credibility of
the kind of assurances you get from
someone like President Putin
representing Russia today let me ask
Tony Brenton so can I can I let me also
on on behalf of President Putin no I
said he said in 2 or 8 at the Bucharest
summit he didn't and it was leaked the
NATO said that if Nader resumes its
expansion and it was resuming there will
be no Ukraine he said that's it right
Tony Brenton the issue of Crimea people
yes I said that I can't speak on behalf
of President Putin but I did see quite a
lot of him when I was ambassador I
judged him then as being a red very
risk-averse man and I was astonished but
it wasn't only me mercifully so is the
Foreign Office the State Department
everybody was taken aback by the seizure
of Crimea and obviously it is sensible
to look again at Russia that having
happened
just didn't understand boy are we
ignoring the views of the people who've
been comprehensively and systematically
vindicated in their analysis and
listening to views of people who've been
comprehensively and systematically wrong
the fact the practice the fact is Russia
Russia Russia is a revisionist part it
regards the post 1991 security order in
Europe as profoundly unfair rightly or
wrongly they don't like you they want to
change it and it's in our vital national
interests that they do not be allowed to
do it and that's all we have to resist
it Julia I'm sorry I just see a
revisionist power
wait wait wait I'm sure Julie has been
waiting to sorry I'm sorry the lady I
just have a question for sir Tony
Britain what you've been talking a lot
about engaging with Russia about
lowering the temperature you named at
least you know name three steps about
what we can do that Russia would accept
and agree to lower the temperature as
well tell us what you would do if you
had that kind of ear being I don't
understand in the my credible okay my
answer is we do a deal on Ukraine the
Russians have been very clear what they
want on Ukraine it's got nothing to do
democracy or any of that they want well
what's the deal is let me feel
please let me respond to your question
they want some sort of guarantee that
Ukraine will not join NATO and they want
some sort of protection autonomy
federalization whatever you call it for
the russian-speaking populations and
I've been saying for the last three
months that I cannot understand why the
West couldn't do this deal way back then
and save an awful lot of blood ships can
I ask if the Ukrainians themselves have
any say in this or is this or are they
to be carved up between the US and
Russia there are the pulses of the west
of this around the suspension of NATO
and even sometimes European against the
will of the most Putin player in the in
Europe that's refer was leading to war
and what Russia did is it created
another firewall and I hope this time it
will work
let's hear both views that gentleman
there I have two questions I'm against
the motion for those for the motion
Shirley engaging means keeping two rules
agreeing rules
what rules do you think that would be
acceptable to put in to those against
the motion what do you suggest is the
alternative to engaging alright what are
the rules keep that for the moment I'm
going to the gentleman there and then
there's someone at the back I'm voting
against the motion
and if helping Russia's border states is
seen as poking the bear how can we not
poke the bear if Russia is to apply
completely different rules to
separatists to its neighbors as it does
to itself Grozny was razed to the ground
not 15 years ago yet if we are seen to
be helping countries with an arrogant
Russian minority then we're seeing as
poking about how can we not help them
right each of you will be able to pick
this up in a moment the lady here I was
I was undecided and I'm beginning to be
Ambu to sway of against emotion well
you've got two minutes so you need to
think quickly and said Sergei tells us
that Russia is mistrusting the West and
I think this habit herein lies the
problem I think the West has trusted
Russia too much they are now being
supplied with their gas to some 60% so
if they hadn't trusted best Russian they
wouldn't have done that right thank you
one more one more view please who's got
the microphone Oh further back I I was
for the motion I've been swinging
backwards and forwards which way you
swinging at the moment
I'm not sure your secret is safe with us
question I've requested person what look
at Tony Brenton could you be more clear
now do you agree with Edward Lucas that
Russia is trying to destabilize the
Baltics alright thank you very briefly
so a couple of quick points which I
think of me on the Baltics no they're
not and and one reason why Russia is not
a threat to us in Europe is of course
because the Baltics members of NATO and
we have that protection there was a very
interesting point made over here and it
cuts to the nub in a way of the problem
of handling Russia which is that
Russia's immediate neighbours Russia
views itself as having an interest in
what happens in them domestically and do
we as civilized people let big States
bully small states and that's a very
fair question about the international
system and our instinctive reaction I
think is no in a civilized world that we
live in that's that sort of thing
shouldn't happen but the brutal fact is
that the civilized world that we think
we've been living in is a world which
has been run in effect by the West and
that world is fading away right Julia
we've been talking again a lot about
engaging with Russia but what I haven't
heard any of you ask is what we do when
Russia Russia stops engaging back with
us so what's the one question you're
putting I mean the answer is so far has
been punishment for breaking
international norms Putin them Putin
himself has said that sanctions have
worked that they have severely
restricted access to money for Russian
companies abroad and he's immediately
walked the line back right at that point
I'm going to just pause and read
something now we have the vote and the
result of the vote now let me remind you
that 31% of you hadn't made up your
minds and 23% of you were against it and
46% were for the idea of engaging with
Putin not castigating him well almost
everyone has
now made up their minds only 3% decided
you hadn't made up your mind but I have
to tell you there's been an
extraordinary shift for engagement 43%
against
54%
so for whatever part of the discussion
gripped you there has been a dramatic
swing from those who were thinking they
would support the motion to those
convinced by the argument on my left by
those against the motion in other words
that there should not be a engagement
with Putin I don't know who's watching
this or listening to it or monitoring it
anywhere at the Russian embassy or
elsewhere but certainly that's the view
of you here in Cadogan Hall in London
having seen that shift our thanks to the
speakers both for the motion and against
the motion
my thanks to intelligence squared for
making this possible and later this
month there will be another debate on
whether queen elizabeth ii should remain
the sovereign of australia it'll come
from Australia but from us here in the
Cadogan Hall in London thank you all
very much indeed